hi guys I'm Greg hi I'm amber amber
Platzer from the amber placer channel
where she constantly plastering how
she's amber on the channel you should go
check out that channel has a lot of
great videos on their reviews reactions
mainly star wars these days find out
what that's all about ships red band
trailer have you seen the show ships no
neither have I I thought a few times
many years ago but this is like the 21
Jump Street reboot up [ __ ] so I feel
like I'm just in the generation that's
just the Ascension yeah about but I knew
I knew that I know that's no that's a
big deal yeah it's about California
Highway Patrol officers I tell the first
trailer for this California Highway
what patrol patrol officers no but why
is it she what's the iron ship what does
it stand for
if you know in the comments let us know
what it is California Highway
immigration patrol officers oh I don't
like but that would be a timely tighter
yeah let's check this out okay play your
back already do this oh my god I love a
little that's a weird way to thank me
for saving your life funny book you're
welcome shooting me with rounds of
kindness maybe nobody cute
we've got to stop shooting Alex that was
my bad we prefer oh that's why from that
armored car job they some of their own
work ball don't want you to go on the
inside telling the cover within a
department er off you're going to be
with a rookie named John Baker you gonna
be granted yeah [ __ ] up man are the
first two female named facilities scores
mean even the lowest standard at 23:30 I
feel pretty darn good I'm on
pharmaceutical regimen that helps a lot
behind that you can mold a man yes ma'am
like a [ __ ] I like you thank you
good night
Thank You Myron up the meal reporters
pretty bad you get all the benefits in a
long time yeah job here are useful for
saving my marriage what are you wearing
my uniform so I thought you probably
wanna see what I look like you know
Brown great done it's like you're three
beers too intimate almost of water so
cool car I got no emotion I'm 30
constantly Michael never can go
[Music]
great are you guys talking [ __ ] I think
you said they like to bike she was
playing around my big I feel like I've
ever beat Boston you make the place look
tiny oh look at your not preying on
girls with low self-esteem
how are you judging them like by their
hair like hell strictest people aren't
yeah that's really shallow
real talk she ate my lunch she ate your
ass everyone's eating everyone asked
what am i hygiene if you go to bathroom
a baby which green light yes your
television tractors good TV we don't
have a [ __ ] bat appeared right I'm
not going to quiz you like a new one
Simon what I knew you well in oral
expecting like with the bus oh yeah
vegetable examine in wild things of
James Wow things have change
oh he gets to use those real life wait
amber realized halfway through that this
was not computing sound especially from
a show like in the 90s or 80s or some
yeah yeah so I kept saying it like the
21 Jump Street reboot I thought I made
this clear no it's probably all your
fault I'm sorry I'm sorry you didn't
catch it on it that had nothing to do
with my own entire Dax Shepard wrote and
directed Oh anybody any looks good like
great I always liked
never really attracted to him I always
thought he was funny I was like an any
Mary Kristen Bell who I think is
probably one of the first people on the
planet she's perfect
yeah she's one of my celebrity crushes
oh yeah totally yeah oh my god she's
Queen and I was like what head with him
we're really well humorous and I was
like he's super retracted all right I
see it now when you get a good body
you're attractive and he's always he was
always funny but yeah she used to play
like creepy he plays like kind of gangly
yeah yeah yeah gangly creepy perverted
dude that's what it was like yeah I saw
him in like turn me off it's kind of
nasty and disgusting this one he does he
seems to be a just a dude is it dude
another idiot idiot cop dude yeah him
and Michael pay me what they have great
chemistry in this I love people Kenyan a
hilarious it was great dramatic actor -
yeah he could do it all I had met
Michael Pena when I first moved down
here and met Michael Pena yeah that's
all and I was the worst to him why
because I was like so what do you do are
you like an actor and and he was so nice
he was so nice he bought me a drink and
was like yeah no I was missed this movie
called crash in and he was like you know
the little girl at the end and I was
like oh my gosh and I was and I look
back on that moment history and I just
cringe and I'm just like amber what were
you doing oh I cried it is beating crash
yeah I just feel bald when I saw each
other for this I was like a little
annoyed because it was like considered
why my jaws are doing Baywatch or doing
[ __ ] and they're all kind of the same
formula now Thanks taking like these 80s
90 shows rebooted them into raunchy are
rigid action comedies and so it's kind
of annoyed by the formula now that
that's kind of just I've grown to just
accept that this is a thing now this is
just something they're doing and now all
i care about is if it's going to be
executed well and right now I saw the
trailer I'm like you know what this
looks like it could be really fun
this
it could be a fun time I have not
expected you haven't accepted now but
the trailer made you asked I'm going to
see it yeah that's my point
so I think I don't know that I will ever
come around to repurposing things
instead of writing original content and
supporting original content but here we
are repurposing things with us guilty of
it yeah but if it's funny then it always
wins with me this is legitimately funny
it looks like a really good time
actually I'm glad of the red band
trailer - yeah they could really get the
naughty r-rated humor I can't believe he
like made mouth to dick contact was it
Michael Tinian like it was dangerously
close look like you really did it huh
they really looked like it really just
got a little up there and smacked him in
the face a little bit and he was just
like look I touched Dax Shepard dick
with my face if it meant I would to be
in a movie I get it I mean I'm saying
saying I touch anyone's dick to my face
design means I could be in a movie
heard Nolan Gilbert Fincher Bay I'm
gonna look even Oh Roseanne Barr anyone
for ya that Mars dick can't really say
much other than this looks funny but it
does it looks legitimately funny and I
need to know what the eye and ship
stands for now interstate interstate ah
right that could be edges your your you
got brains you got the brain I got the
brain debris you got the brawn what is
it
is that from like Captain Planet or
something
alright subscribe to the real rejects
and while you're at it this is going
well subscribe and reply search it'll
kind of videos of it this is the feds
laughing yeah we're killing it you
should check out her reviews on Star
Wars seriously if you're a chips man
you're gonna love the Star Wars video
it's likely her and another friend from
afterbuzz TV strip where do you do lives
that you do like attribution
was there something on it yeah I do I
review TV shows on afterbuzz TV which is
like an after-show Network they have a
podcast and then you can also I don't
I'm not another audio learner so for
people like me they have where you can
watch our faces on their YouTube yeah
but the popular thing is actually the
iTunes podcast what we do I tried
watching one of those videos you're in
but I never saw the show that was really
bored hurt so I didn't continue watch
it's for super fans of that show so like
if you're not super into that show like
we break down every episode right very
intensely educators now we're long yeah
yeah yeah couldn't get into it yeah look
go check it yes you're the sugar and
this is a our halt and catch fire or why
don't those of the shows that I can it
shows on TV yeah they're only shows that
I didn't going to be like I don't watch
nothing on what I like